views and opinions expressed on this
program are those of the guests
appearing on the program and do not
necessarily reflect the views and
opinions of 8 news now or next our media
group
[Music]
tonight on politics now nevada's still
on pause what our state
task force says about the rising number
of cases plus
we're developing messages right now and
for various groups
a look at nevada's plan to get people to
take a vaccine when it becomes available
and everybody can go register so
nobody had to hack into anything the
i-team digs into how much fraud there is
in our unemployment system
and our scammers are pulling it off
[Music]
from eight news now this is politics now
thank you very much for joining us i'm
john langler and we start with the fight
against the coronavirus
there is still no word whether nevada
will implement tighter covid
restrictions next week
our case positivity rate is about 22
percent
nevada is now second in the country for
positive test percentages
nevada's covert 19 task force reports
more active cases now
than during the summer peak state health
officials estimate there are nearly 28
000 active cases of code covid 19 in
nevada
although there is good news in terms of
the overall percentage of cases
fewer people are dying evidence
continues to suggest not specifically in
nevada but nationally and
internationally
that any any setting that where there's
an opportunity for people to be unmasked
has a higher a higher chance for disease
transmission
governor sysolak's three-week pause on
business and other activities ends next
tuesday
the state's coveted 19 response director
says the governor is taking
all of this new data under advisement
the fda is expected to issue an
emergency use authorization for the
pfizer kovid 19 vaccine
an advisory panel approved it on
thursday our washington dc correspondent
alexander limon has the latest
and that concludes the vote so we do
have a favorable vote
the fda advisory panel voted in favor of
approving
pfizer's covid19 vaccine this after the
fda heard
hours of testimony thursday pfizer's
senior vice president of clinical
research and development told the fda
the company hasn't found serious safety
concerns
injection site pain was observed
frequently fever and chills along with
other systemic manifestations were
observed
the pfizer executive also said the side
effects are usually mild to moderate and
consistent with what's expected from a
trial that involves many people who are
older
or have comorbidities evan fine a
participant in the pfizer trial told the
fda
he believes he received the real vaccine
experienced only mild side effects and
has not contracted covet 19
in the five months since his first dose
absent compelling reason not to
authorize it
it is simply immoral and unethical to
deny the vaccine to health care workers
or first responders who want it
nevada senator jackie rosen has a
message for americans worrying the
vaccine was developed too quickly
we have to trust the scientists there's
no
ulterior motives if that's what people
are thinking of
the whole world we've got it works virus
is attacking all of us and we have to
get out of it together
despite emergency use authorization for
the vaccine the fda and pfizer say they
will continue to monitor and study
participants in the trials
and the effects of the vaccine in
washington
alexandra limon so in light of this
decision expect to see a public
vaccination campaign by the southern
nevada health district when the vaccines
are formally approved kristin drummond
shows us this effort
and who it plans to target preparing for
a covet 19 vaccine campaign roll
out we're developing messages right now
and
for various groups the southern nevada
health district finalizes facts to soon
share with the public
we'll have a faq pretty soon on our
website
and some information there on how to get
the vaccine
joanne rue piper is the director of
clinical services at the health district
she says the effort targets everyone
including minority communities
we have specific funding for hispanic
families and african-american families
because those
groups have been affected by kovid more
than others
how difficult do you think it may be to
try and convince
people to take the vaccine to me it's
very unknown at this point we need to
move forward
dr jeffrey ebersole studies immune
system responses
the immunologist at unlv understands
some
question the effectiveness the reality
is that both of these companies have
been working with these
this type of nucleic acid vaccine for
probably a decade
he says the vaccine includes a part of
the virus that triggers an immune
response
you get it injected into your arm your
muscle cells pick up this
rna and then our own cells
actually make the antigen the potential
cure to bringing normalcy to the
community
with the help of health leaders we'll
use all of our
tools that we can to get people to take
a vaccine
kristen drummond 8 news now so in
congress the next step is passing a
covett 19 relief bill
the house passed a temporary government
funding bill this week
to try and buy more time for talks
i feel like i've been a broken record
you know i represent the state that's
been the most economically
ravaged from this pandemic and so i have
been
pleading with anyone i can for us to get
a package way back in may i mean when we
pass the heroes
act and then in september again and so
nothing gets congress moving quite like
a deadline so
i'm hoping that people on the other side
of the aisle can see
the need that is nevada democratic
congresswoman susie lee
she says 900 billion dollars in this
stimulus deal it's not enough
but it's better than nothing she says
she adds more stimulus is going to be
needed in the future
however congresswoman lee would have
voted for
this one to get us through the year
however senate
minority leader chuck schumer and house
speaker nancy pelosi they're rejecting
that proposal
now a new deal is on the table that
includes direct payments to you and me
the plan is from the white house it is
slightly more than the last package
calls for a 600 direct payment to
americans who are suffering but does not
offer additional money for unemployment
both sides also remain deadlocked over
funding for state and local governments
and liability protections for
organizations
and republicans see no need to send huge
subs of money to state and local
governments whose tax revenues have
actually gone up
well i think cutting unemployment to the
to
virtually almost nothing is a very very
bad
idea both sides say they hope a deal can
be reached by christmas
a las vegas man is accused of putting
threatening posts on governor steve
sisolak's official facebook page
prosecutors say this man named steven
feeder posted at least
34 times calling the governor a tyrant
court records claim feeder made the
posts back in may he allegedly told a
detective he was quote very angry and
upset over the governor's covet 19
response and one of the posts
says in part quote tyrant as the tyrant
has declared war on people
and like hong kong protesters we need to
arm ourselves and form a
militia and fight back federer's lawyer
says his
client never acted on what he wrote and
he has a right to free speech
to immigration now for the first time
since 2017 the daca program is open to
new applicants
this protects undocumented immigrants
brought here as children from
deportation
orcomena explains what this could mean
for nevadas
this means the trump administration has
to fully restore daca an
obama-era initiative now approximately 1
million
undocumented immigrants including
thousands here in nevada
could benefit from it new applications
for daca which stands for deferred
action for childhood arrivals
have not been accepted for about three
years but on friday a federal judge
ordered the u.s department of homeland
security to take in applications for
immigrants who qualify
daca shield certain people who came to
the u.s as children
from deportation which means they can
stay in the country for two years
subject to renewal the judge also said
approved applicants should get work
permits that last for two years
and current daca recipients known as
dreamers can travel abroad and return to
america
there are currently more than 640 000
dreamers in the u.s
and according to the american
immigration council over 12 thousand
dreamers
lived in nevada as of march 2020. local
attorneys say
many more can now be helped we thought
that we would have to wait until
president-elect biden came into office
for uscis to start accepting those
applications but this order is making it
very clear
that uscis has to accept them so there's
no longer
there's no longer a waiting period it's
time to it's time to apply
requirements for daca eligibility
include having no serious criminal
convictions
arriving in the u.s before age 16 living
here since at least 2007
and earning an american high school
diploma ged
or serving in the military many are
calling this new order a victory for
dreamers but the fight
isn't necessarily over yet a dhs
spokesman says while the department
will comply with the decision they are
working with the justice department
on next steps to appeal reporting in las
vegas
orca mana 8 news now next on politics
now getting to the bottom of
unemployment fraud we found
in one case uh 2 000 claimants that
shared
the same mailing address coming up the
i-team finds out just how
many city and state employees have had
their ids stolen
as the number of coronavirus cases grows
so does the number of nevadans
victimized by unemployment fraud
there are still many unanswered
questions about how this fraud is
happening in the first place
but it is an issue the item is following
vanessa murphy has next door
[Music]
from a rapper who made a song bragging
about unemployment fraud and was
later arrested for the crime to a mail
carrier who prosecutors say was part of
a scheme to use addresses on her route
to help collect the debit cards
employment departments are overwhelmed
due to job losses from the covet 19
pandemic
schemers see an opportunity and fraud is
so bad
nevada's department of employment
training and rehabilitation also known
as dieter
is still analyzing the numbers to figure
out how much money it paid to people who
shouldn't have received it what happened
i think initially
is there was a desire to pay as many
legitimate claimants as possible as
fast as possible mike schmidt runs a las
vegas i.t
company and he's on the deter strike
force a group
trying to solve problems at the agency
including fraud
he says his team tried to match
claimants with department of motor
vehicle records
they're finding alarming patterns and
alerting law enforcement
we found in one case
2000 claimants that shared the same
mailing address
schmidt says the system was built for
convenience one reason why fraudulent
applications weren't caught before the
money was paid
everybody could go register so nobody
had to hack in anything nobody had to
break into anything
but personal information is being stolen
to file fraudulent
claims alisa cafferata who heads deters
says it's not happening within the
agency
what we're seeing and what other states
are seeing is that this is
a result of data breaches that have
happened to other companies and the
information is out
in the dark web and the criminal
activity
is certainly concerted
the i-team has been trying to find out
how the information is stolen
in the first place reaching out to
agencies like the fbi
and the u.s postal inspection which
investigate the fraud
that's something we're still looking
into and i don't want to comment
too soon on that we don't have a
concrete answer as to where
they're getting that information from
the question is well then how do you
stop it if you don't know how it's
starting yeah that's a good question
and that i don't have the answer for but
you know the only thing we can do is we
can you know preach prevention
just for people to check to make sure
that they haven't had unemployment filed
in their name and if they
find out they have to report that right
away the i-team obtained the numbers for
some public employees who have become
victims clark county reports out of its
approximately 10
thousand employees 1120 have been the
subjects of fraudulent claims
the city of north las vegas reports 282
las vegas reports 568
and henderson reports 615 while victims
are urged to report fraud to law
enforcement
and deter cafferata says employers can
play a major role in stopping it also
we give them a notice that a claim has
been filed on an employee and several
times
those employees are still working so as
soon as they
log into their portal and let us know we
can stop payments
on those claims vanessa murphy reporting
there
so the head of deter says staff are so
overwhelmed with unemployment cases now
they can't follow up on a lot of these
fraud claims
but as long as you have filed the
correct documentation it should and will
be addressed
every morning thousands of nevadans are
waking up and looking at their
unemployment portal they're trying to
figure out if they've had that claim
processed
joe mohler shares one story of
navigating not having a job
to get by as they wait for their
unemployment benefits today we came to
east las vegas to speak to a woman
who is getting desperate for answers
regarding her claim as she continues
to live in her brother's garage
unfortunately right now i stay
in his garage with my puppy i don't have
a bathroom
i don't have a kitchen this is nyree
mcgee
it's a little harsh excuse me i get it's
just it's different for me i'm 28
you know i've always worked i've never
been on welfare
unemployment she says she has to live in
this garage as she waits for answers
regarding her unemployment benefits
this month be nine months on the fourth
it was nine months nine months
no pay she says she worked at a beauty
supply store that was forced to close
due to the pandemic
right now she relies on her mom who
lives in another state
my mom she's like my rock she helps me
out as best she can
she told us she sent in paperwork that
was asked from her twice
and has one pending resolution and asked
again in august and i also provided that
to them too
and it's just been pending i've called i
talked to
customer service reps for dieter and
they have um
just let me know to just wait she is
hoping to find another place to live
once she gets some benefits
after contracting covet herself earlier
in the fall she said her job search has
not been easy
nine months after filing she still
checks online frequently
every other day yeah every other day
and praying to god that it changes or
they set an interview for me to speak
with someone
mcgee says she will continue to look for
a job and all she can do right now is
wait and just keep checking her portal
reporting in east las vegas joe moeller
8 news now
dieter tells us week five of the lost
wages assistance
situation that is still being paid out
it could take another week
the state trust fund that pays out
regular unemployment insurance benefits
is almost out of money dieter says
that's just about one week's worth of
payments left in that account
federal officials have been told about
this everyone on unemployment is still
going to get that money so nevada
instead is going to start borrowing from
the department of labor
34 other states are already doing the
same thing because their trust funds for
unemployment ran out as well
coming up on politics now president
donald trump is still fighting
up next his latest strategy to try and
keep president-elect biden
from taking the white house you're
watching
politics now
the nevada supreme court has denied the
trump campaign's request to overturn the
election results here in our state
judges unanimously agreed with a lower
court judge who found
no evidence of widespread voter fraud
states submitted their certified
election results this week
that narrows president donald trump's
hopes of overturning the 2020 election
as our washington d.c correspondent
kelly meyer found
many capitol hill republicans are
putting plans for a biden presidency on
pause
senator marco rubio isn't ready to say
who won
the 2020 election what i said i would
accept is ultimately
what states certify legally through
their process and the electoral college
decides that's how our system works
rubio says he's letting the process play
out i do think there are some things
that happen in this election
that need to be we need to go back and
look at the florida republican says
while his
state was prepared for the flood of
mail-in ballots this year
many others were not and it caused all
sorts of delays in the vote counting
process that is undermine the confidence
of a significant percentage of the
american people on the result
republicans on capitol
hill are pushing back on planning for
abiding transition
until after the electoral college
results are finalized
democrats tell me the delays are
dangerous
we have a centuries-long tradition of
the peaceful transfer of power north
carolina democrat david price
is encouraging his colleagues to be
honest about the results and stand up to
the president
it really is distressing that
republicans will not call his hand rubio
says he doesn't know if president trump
will attend the inauguration of
president-elect joe biden he's not a
politician he doesn't operate in an
orthodox way
but rubio doesn't expect that day to end
the president's political career
look at the president runs he's going to
be the nominee
and and i think he's going to win the
electoral college casts its votes on
december 14th
reporting in washington i'm kelly meyer
back here at home the 2021 nevada
legislative session starts in february
lawmakers are busy putting in their
billed draft requests and there are
already 600 of them
several hundred have a description
already attached so let's
go through a few of those on the state
senate side first
senate bill 3 gives nevada judges a 30
thousand dollar a year pay raise
it applies to justices in the state
supreme court the court of appeals and
district court judges
it's sponsored by the senate committee
on finance illegal fireworks are a
bigger problem every year and senate
bill 4
increases the fine for using them it
allows county commissioners to pass
ordinances regulating fireworks and
create criminal penalties
a maximum civil pine would fine would be
up to 50 000 dollars for a single
violation
this measure was sponsored by the senate
committee on government affairs
senate bill 36 tackles the growing
problem of student suicides
it requires every school board to create
a committee that would develop a plan to
respond to a crisis
an emergency or a suicide and they would
also have to include specific
information about how this would work
during a pandemic
this was sponsored by the senate
committee on education
senate bill 39 would modernize the way
the state accepts
money it would allow people to pay
government entities by credit card
electronic transfer or even bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies
the treasurer would have to get
permission for this last one
and that last effort thing i just
referenced and that was sponsored by the
senate committee on government affairs
next week we're going to look at a few
of the bills on the assembly side that
will come up
in the next legislative session this
week in what to watch we're keeping a
close eye on our state's three-week
coronavirus pause
next tuesday marks three weeks since
governor sisalek told everybody to stay
home
and our coveted numbers have not gone
down so we're waiting to see if we might
see some title restrictions from the
governor
on tuesday nevada's presidential
electors cast their votes for democrat
joe biden on monday
the electoral college meets in all 50
states that cast their votes
biden should get at least 306 of the
elector votes
electoral votes rather well above the
necessary 270
to win the white house we'll keep an eye
on all of those things all week long
that'll do it for us here on politics
now we thank you very much for watching
to stay up to date on all the political
news across nevada just go to eight
newsnow dot com and we'll see you
every saturday thank you very much for
watching and have a good rest of the
[Music]
weekend
you